une année 2023 qui s'ouvre de la
meilleure des manières avec l'examen de
ce texte important un texte qui vise à
accélérer les procédures administratives
de construction de nouveaux réacteurs
électronucléaires en France et ainsi à
raccourcir les délais de réalisation de
ses projets ce texte permet également de
baisser les coûts de ces projets en
réduisant la capitalisation d'intérêt
ainsi que la prime de risque je rappelle
enfin que les charges de en effet que
les charges de capital peuvent
représenter pour un projet de nouveaux
nucléaires jusqu'à pouvoir plus de 50%
du coût complet d'électricité donc c'est
pas complètement l'épaisseur du trait
dont nous discuterons avant de rentrer
très concrètement dans le contenu du
texte quelques mots sur le contexte ce
contexte est d'abord celui de l'urgence
d'une crise climatique qui menace nos
écosystèmes nos sociétés l'avenir de nos
enfants d'une crise qui doit nous amener
à réduire drastiquement et durablement
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
d'ici 2050 le contexte c'est ensuite
celui de la crise énergétique que
connaît notre pays notre continent
depuis l'année dernière la guerre qui se
déroule en ce moment aux portes de
l'Europe en Ukraine remet profondément
en cause notre approvisionnement et
fragilise notre économie du fait de
prime énergie qui se sont envolés ces
deux crises ont la même cause ou en tout
cas la même cause centrale notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles qu'il
s'agisse du gaz du charbon ou du pétrole
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'ambition
du président de la République et du
gouvernement menée par la première
ministre et de devenir le premier grand
pays industriel à sortir de cette
dépendance aux énergies fossiles c'est
un impératif climatique bien sûr c'est
un impératif pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français avoir une énergie abondante et
peu chère ou moins cher un impératif
pour la capacité d'investissement de nos
colitivité et la compétitivité de nos
entreprises un impératif pour notre
indépendance énergétique et on le voit
elle est souvent reliée à l'indépendance
politique